I want to show you a little intuitive
eating hack that will completely change
your perspective and your relationship
with your fear foods like cookies if
your goal is to put your fear Foods on
the same playing field as all other
Foods you need to literally put them on
the same plate so I want you to take the
food that you deem as like junk or bad
or unhealthy and literally put it on the
same plate as other foods that provide
more nourishment visually seeing the
healthy and unhealthy Foods on the same
plate puts them on the same playing
field it rips them off of their pedestal
it makes them all just another food that
can be enjoyed in moderation so you
don't have to have a full out cookie
binge or a super strict clean eating day
so try this little exercise at yourself
and let me know how it goes
mmm